el 26 de enero de 2014 tres años después
del inicio de la primavera árabe los
diputados tunecinos aprobaron una nueva
constitución el artículo primero era el
mismo que el de la constitución anterior
que data de 1959
túnez es un estado libre independiente y
soberano su religión es el islam su
lengua el árabe y su sistema el
republicano
el texto combina el laicismo y el islam
por primera vez en un país árabe la
constitución garantiza la libertad de
creencia y de conciencia y el libre
ejercicio de la religión la sharia no se
menciona como parte de la ley sin
embargo ocho años después el presidente
tunecino caixa yet propone un proyecto
muy diferente
su objetivo es dar al jefe de estado una
fuente de poder incontestable
permitiendo la inmunidad durante toda la
duración de su mandato la nueva
constitución también reduce
considerablemente el papel y el poder
del parlamento y pretende instaurar una
segunda cámara la asamblea nacional de
regiones creadas según el modelo de los
senados franceses y estadounidense uno
de los puntos más polémicos preocupa en
lugar del islam el artículo 5 del
proyecto presidencial afirma que túnez
forma parte de la umma islámica dentro
de un sistema democrático sólo el estado
deberá velar y garantizar los objetivos
del islam esto ha sido criticado por los
partidarios de la separación de la
religión y del estado